money can be awkward topic of
conversation many Americans say they
would rather talk about almost anything
else
a recent Capital Group survey asked more
than 1,200 adults what topics they
considered too taboo to discuss with
friends income retirement savings and
the amount of debt were at the very top
marital problems political views and
drug use were ranked as less
controversial CBS News business analyst
that's Jill Schlesinger is here to guide
us through the difficult financial
conversations that she says we should be
having at home I was certainly raised in
one of these homes Jill where you don't
discuss money my mother used to say it's
impolite I would say all the kids are
teasing me they say I'm just a rich
little girl and she said we're not rich
we're just comfortable so when I said
how much does daddy makes she said
that's not something that you need to
know well why is it so hard I think it
really is hard because of course many of
us were raised with the families where
we didn't discuss that and it was not
seemed to be polite but you know this is
one of those social taboos that has
endured and as we said in this survey
unlike maybe sex or politics which seems
to be pretty open conversation we still
have a problem about money I think it's
really okay a psychologist once said to
me the thing about money is it's
concrete and so all of our emotions all
of our unresolved issues our fears and
anxieties it can be lumped into a money
issue and it really can bring up some
feelings of inadequacy as well and that
can really make it hard to have open
dialogue and it's about what you put
your priorities on if you spend your
money this is more important than that
and people fight over priorities so
you're having a conversation with your
spouse a lot of people turn to financial
advisors what should you keep with the
financial advisor and what must you
really talk about with your spouse I
think you have to have open dialogue but
you have to do it in a safe place you
don't do it in the middle of a fight Oh
John I'm so mad at you you spent this
now let's have our money conversation
you want to pick a good time in a place
you want to have some ground rules no
judgments right we're gonna try to just
calm down we're gonna say here's what I
have maybe you have a little secret
account you've been hiding maybe you've
got some debt you've been racking up
check-in with each other about your
financial priorities maybe one of you
wants to send your kids to college and
pay the whole thing the other one might
say I don't want to do that I want
try to retire by the time I'm 64 you've
got to have these conversations you've
got to have openness and you're
absolutely right though if there are
problems bringing in an unbiased third
party a financial adviser a CPA is a
great idea secret accounts never sound
like a good idea in a marriage I'm not
opposed it comes to talking when it
comes to talking to children yeah you
know there's more and more research out
there about that it should begin very
early the discussion about finances
absolutely because money habits are
actually formed by the time you are
seven years old so you want to demystify
some of the aspects of money but that's
Amin you have to share how much you make
you want them to be comfortable with the
topic and it is absolutely imperative to
have real conversations hard
conversations with your kids as they
enter high school and say this is what
our family can do in terms of college
this is our expectation you have to do
this the other thing and you want to
guide those kids to develop good money
habits and they can talk about it not
just in the family but amongst friends
and at the workplace when it comes to
salaries in that particular this is a
really touchy issue and I think that I
was certainly raised where you don't
talk about this with your family and
your friends but having open
conversations at work can reveal pay
disparity it may help you seek a mentor
seek a manager who can guide you talk to
your friends outside of work try to
demystify this topic you may end up
making more money by having these open
comers I know a specific example of
where that happened where a younger
woman discussed it openly found out a
male was making more than her and was
able to remedy that issue by sharing
that information our conversations but
well worth yeah yeah break the taboo yes
indeed all right Jim thanks so much for
being with us